[Musique]
chers amis les 23 et 24 mars prochain se
tient notre congrès du MoDem à Blois un
congrès tout d'abord c'est important
parce que ça ne se tient que tous les 3
ans la dernière fois que j'en ai connu
un mois en tant que jeunne démocrate
c'était en 2020 dans un contexte un peu
particulier avec le covid en distantiel
donc cette fois-ci c'est l'occasion de
se retrouver physiquement de partager
des moments de convivialité et surtout
un congrès c'est un moment où on
rappelle ce que le modem est ce que le
modem porte dans le débat public et dans
les temps qu'on connaît c'est
particulièrement important de faire
entendre cette voix de notre famille
politique des démocrates ce congrès il
est aussi important par parce qu'il se
tient à Blois Blois une très belle ville
un très beau territoire et c'est aussi
l'occasion de rappeler que le modem est
un mouvement engagé dans pour la
décentralisation et engagé pour ces
territoires donc pour toutes ces raisons
je vous invite à venir nombreux et
nombreuses à Blois les 23 et 24 mars
[Musique]
prochain